[Music]
when president biden announced his
vaccine mandate plan in september gallup
reported that roughly six in ten adults
favored the requirements for federal
government workers employees of large
companies and workers at hospitals 58 of
employed people in gallup's september
polling supported their employer
requiring employees without a medical
exemption to get the jab while 36
percent were opposed in an early october
axios ipsos poll 27 said their employer
was requiring them to get one up from 16
in august americans believe their fellow
citizens should make the choice
themselves about getting a vaccine in
august usa today ipsos poll found that
72 percent of americans agreed that
people have a right not to get the
vaccine at the same time 70 said that
unvaccinated people should not expect to
be around vaccinated people 65 said the
unvaccinated should be barred from large
events and separately from traveling by
plane
at this time most americans don't see
the vaccine as an infringement on
personal liberty
do you think americans should be
required to get the cova vaccine let us
know in our poll also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from aei